proszę państwa
widzimy to Jak na dłoni yy
Jak punkt widzenia
zmienia się w zależności OD punktu siedzenia
teraz yy kiedy ten nową składkę zdrowotną yy
pobiera Donald tusk
to jest to to
są to pieniądze bardzo potrzebne budżetowi yy
kiedy to samo robił Jarosław Kaczyński
to oczywiście było złodziejstwo i marnatrafcie haracz
yy ale trzeba zdawać sobie sprawę
że w istocie tak właśnie jest yy
proszę państwa
200 miliardów z budżetu
na świadczenie opieki zdrowotnej
plus ponad 100 miliardów
które polacy wydają
z własnych kieszeni na prywatne świadczenia zdrowotne
to w sumie jest ponad 300 miliardów na yy
świadczenia zdrowotne
to wychodzi prawie zł8.000 na obywatela
za zł8.000 na obywatela
szanowni państwo
można mieć ubezpieczenie medyczne
godne arabskiego szejka
już nawet niektórzy dostawcy usług bankowych
w ramach pakietu bankowego
za kilkaset złotych miesięcznie
200 zł300 miesięcznie oferują
świadczenie opieki medycznej na całym świecie
to ile można mieć za 8.000
tu jest pies pogrzebany proszę państwa
w systemie wady są w systemie
ale mimo wszystko
należy apelować do premiera tuska
o wywiązanie się ze swojej przedwyborczej obietnicy
zorganizowania składki zdrowotnej yy
która nie tylko jest przekierowaniem szmalu do budżetu
centralnego i zabraniem
pieniędzy samorządom kosztem pitów
ale stanowi także przykrył obowiązek biurokratyczny dla
przedsiębiorców
bo oni mają w związku z tym
kolejne deklaracje do składania
i tuczy się dzięki temu biznes yy księgowo-podatkowy